[Musique]
nous embarquons un inspecteur de la dps
de la dpsp sénégalaise à bord pour
allier effectivement le savoir-faire au
sein de l'aéronef la vitesse du vecteur
et aussi la connaissance de la zone de
l'inspecteur des pêches sénégalais donc
il y a vraiment un travail de
coopération et de coordination qui
fonctionne très bien jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
j'ai fait du mal à ça
c'est patrouille permettent de mieux
connaître les activités de pêche qui se
déroulent dans nos eaux
et le cas échéant de faire
des arraisonnements donc lorsque nous
faisons face à des infractions au
règlement de la pêche
principalement des assonnements qui sont
liés à des cas de pêche non autorisés
ou de pêche dans des zones interdites